zayn malik has pleaded no contest to
harassing his ex gigi hadid and her
mother yolanda hadid the 28 year old
singer was charged with four criminal
offenses of harassment according to
court documents obtained by e.t the
alleged incident occurred on september
29th at the pennsylvania home where the
model and zayn have been raising their
13 month old daughter kai the former one
direction member allegedly quote shoved
yolanda into a dresser causing mental
anguish and physical pain after shouting
profanities at the 57 year old former
real housewives of beverly hills star
per the documents tension increased with
zane allegedly telling gigi over the
phone to quote strap on some [ __ ]
balls and defend your partner against
your [ __ ] mother in my house
the singer reportedly pleaded no contest
to charges on wednesday and was fined he
was put on a 90-day probation for each
of his four counts
360 days total and was ordered to
complete an anger management class and
domestic violence program zane must not
contact yolanda or the security guard
that was on the property during the
incident whom he allegedly attempted to
fight
according to the docs the judge could
terminate the probation if all
conditions are met within six months
of course this all comes after a source
told et that yolanda and zane had a
disagreement that turned hostile
adding that gigi was not there when the
alleged incident transpired and she
listened to both sides of the story
a rep for gigi told et on thursday
gigi is solely focused on the best for
kai she asks for privacy during this
time
on thursday after news broke of the
alleged altercation zane posted a
lengthy message to twitter which read in
part quote as you all know i am a
private person and i very much want to
create a safe and private space for my
daughter to grow up in a place where
private family matters aren't thrown on
the world stage for all to poke and pick
apart in an effort to protect that space
for her i agreed to not contest claims
arising from an argument i had with a
family member of my partners who entered
our home while my partner was away
several weeks ago
zane ended the statement by writing that
he's hoping for quote healing for all
involved despite some apparently harsh
words he claims were shared
zane later released another statement to
tmz saying he adamantly denies striking
yolanda adding quote for the sake of my
daughter i declined to give any further
details and i hope that yolanda will
reconsider her false allegations and
move towards healing these family issues
in private
zayn and gigi have been on and off for
years starting in 2015.
he's obviously so gorgeous but
really the way that we could have
conversations and kind of just
were really interested in the same
things and it was really easy and in
early 2020 gigi announced they were
expecting their first child together on
the tonight show we're very excited and
and happy and grateful for everyone's
well wishes and support the pair
welcomed baby kai later that same year
but before all that back in 2017 yolanda
praised her daughter's partner while
speaking to e.t
he's just a really good person you know
he comes from very humble beginnings so
he's just a normal guy and he's a good
human being he's special
you